um is this an earthquake here at Yahoo
well settlement yeah I mean it's a big
development no question about that my
take is that's a it's somewhat of a
victory particularly for Marissa Meyer
insofar as she gets to keep her job at
least for now right starboard was coming
in guns blazing they wanted to replace
the entire board including Marissa at
least now she gets us a job she gets a
say in the fate of the company they're
actively looking for a buyer they've
gotten lots of bids we've been reporting
on it really aggressively here verizon
seems to be one of the main companies
that wants to buy them Marissa gets to
keep a seat on the board she gets to
keep her job at least for now I'm told
her relationship be with these new
independent directors to the board well
she said very clearly she wants to be
actively she's actively engaged in
seeking a buyer there was reports early
on that she was kind of removed from
that process but Yahoo and everybody
that we've talked to close to the
situation is indicated she's very
committed to a very thorough process at
the same time she's got to keep the
trains running inside the company she's
got to keep people from jumping ship so
she's got to be remain very very
involved in day-to-day operations and
keeping everybody at Yahoo from you know
just kind of getting out of there Tom
giving these four new people on the
board are going to throw a wrench into
any kind of acquisition plans well my
sense is no jeff smith the c.e.o
starboard is also going to be on the
committee that's involved in the in
deciding who buys Yahoo where how that
ends up you've got an investment banker
on their tour Bram formerly of joy bank
you've got a former a media executive
and you've got a technologist on there
so it's a their their credentials are
fairly impeccable